hello everyone and welcome back to
another episode of Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong I am surrounded today by two of
the M's Mr Mark Ellis and Mr Scott
I'm a Man Mark Ellis well Scott is great
to have you back here today he is a host
QA moderator and a film critic and
somebody who I know was definitely
talking about these two films when they
were in theaters and I'm sure on the
radio and on TV we're talking of course
about Mr Martin scorsese's two most
iconic films because it is 80th birthday
on November 17th literally 60 years of
making movies still at the top of his
game this week we're going to be
breaking down Good Fellas and casino
that is like really kind of crazy are
you a big Gambler I am not a big Gambler
except when I go to the movies really
what about you Mark you are not you are
not anything I do enjoy some Blackjack
really yeah I love sitting out of the
tank able I love talking some white
trash and having some fun with the
dealer but I also was introduced to the
modern concept of video Blackjack which
is great because whenever I'm ready to
go back into my normal introverted self
which people don't believe it happens I
just love playing video Blackjack
because you just play by yourself and
it's cheaper
um I will go ahead and let's get a
little bit more dived into it again it's
Martin scorsese's 80th birthday he's a
Scorpio just like this guy yeah every
time he talks about uh Rotten Tomatoes
is when I realize he's a Scorpio
uh Band shout out to Ben Morris uh sorry
Ben Norris I just watched Casino again
recently it's such an underappreciated
classic with every performance being
top-notch I think it's unfairly judged
against Goodfellas which is excellent by
its own merits must ask Goodfellas
versus casinos again you guys are the
best thanks for the work that you do
first of all Ben I love you for
comparing these two because you wanted
to ask the question I will say this I I
don't think it's even a good comparison
because these two films are so similar
and I think the only fault they had is
that they're too similar I I feel like
not only are they too similar but they
came out too close apart let's just say
five years five years five years there
wasn't enough time to miss Goodfellas
and then boom you got Casino like let's
say Casino came out 15 years later then
then you know in that case it'll be like
oh man we haven't had a good like you
know Goodfellas type of movie from
Scorsese in a really long time you would
have been hungry for casino but in the
case of coming out five years later like
didn't we just see this what's
interesting with casino is it happens a
lot with directors of Martin scorsese's
ilk which I feel like they want to get a
do-over like as much as Martin Scorsese
loves Goodfellas if you hear them
talking about it like it was a very hard
production and it was sure very
challenging and he didn't I think get
the story as well as he would have
wanted because if you really look at the
film it is like a tight and I'm talking
murderous hour and 15 minutes and then
the last hour or so gets a little bit
more meandered if you judge them by the
two halves well well what's great about
Goodfellas compared to casino is that
first of all good Fellas is a a good 45
minutes shorter than casino and that's
you talk about it being a tight film
yeah you feel it but here's the thing
like what's great about Goodfellas is
that it's the it's the rise it's the
good times and then it's the downfall
when when like they everyone gets their
comeuppance it's the consequence of
living this life to that extent the way
that Goodfellas is structured was very
much uh the way that Paul Thomas
Anderson structured exactly it's like
very very similar now wait wait Casino
doesn't have is that same defined rise
and fall which is what makes Goodfellas
a better movie one thing I will say also
about Boogie Nights the fall in Boogie
Nights is so much better that was the
part about Goodfellas the altar former
altar boy the Martin Scorsese was yeah
he was always dabbling with the evil he
could never get with the evil that
wasn't biblical which was violence
remember all of the violence is what
Scorsese is known for that's biblical
it's embracing the full it's it's
embracing what full downfall yeah it's
embracing the full downfall you can even
see it in the taxi driver
um oh Shameless plug uh I recently did a
conversation with Quentin Tarantino for
his new book Cinema speculation and yeah
and one of the chapters or one of the
books that he really dives into is taxi
driver and this hypothetical that taxi
driver was originally supposed to be
directed by Brian De Palma the script
and it went to Scorsese and if you look
at it Martin Scorsese never betrays
Travis Bickel he always treats him very
kindly and that's the same way he treats
his characters in this one and I think
in Goodfellas he gets the bravado so
well but when you show his downfall it
almost feels like Henry what are you
doing when it should really be like yeah
we know where you're going Henry well
the thing about these two movies though
is that I feel like the critics got more
fatigue with from Goodfellas to casino
than the odd audience it because the
audience either one of these movies are
just such great Breezy watches which is
weird when you talk about how in-depth
and like detailed the subject matter is
but if it's on TV it just immediately
sucks you in and Goodfellas in Casino
feel like one long giant piece and So
Good Fellas 96 certified fresh on the
Tomato Meter Casino dips down it's still
certified fresh but it's only 79 yeah
but the audience score for both of them
are in the 90 percentiles interesting
Goodfellas being 97 and casino being 93
and so you know when I I think I did a
verses um on Rotten Tomatoes right here
uh of Scorsese versus Spielberg but it's
like Scorsese is more known for like
this sort of thing where Spielberg he
gets the rap of being the Blockbuster
guy but he's also done a lot of smaller
movies or different different genres
where Stacy has done that like go watch
a movie like Hugo but then this is what
he's most known for and so I think the
comparison is that where it's like
Casino or Goodfellas and into Ben's
point there are fans out there that are
like no I I would rather watch Casino
than Goodfellas I I think scorsese's uh
Spielberg's most Scorsese type movie is
Munich yeah Munich feels like the most
like a Scorsese film but you're right
Spielberg is more known for the
Blockbuster stuff which where some of
Spielberg's best movies are actually uh
uh closer to scorsese's sensibilities
like obviously uh like Munich but also
you know Saving Private Ryan I mean
there's a lot of there's a lot of
bridges stuff like that yeah before we
get too far though I definitely want to
make sure that we at least set the stage
a little bit
um and sort of like Get where we are but
first first and foremost I need to get
our definitive answer which or which oh
that's absolutely hands down Good Fellas
are you kidding good Fellas without
question Rotten Tomatoes is right about
this for sure I think on both fronts I
think the the number itself yeah is
pretty accurate for both Goodfellas and
casino I agree I agree because I don't
think that casino is a big that film I
just think that it came out too close to
Goodfellas it's only five years it is
too similar it ain't good though and it
ain't good Fellas now what if what if
Casino Jacqueline Coley what if Casino
came out first hmm what if Casino came
out in 1990 and then Goodfellas came out
five years later how will the scores
really change on Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong I mean I don't know but I have a
hard time with it because I'm in a
different place because I actually like
before we get to that question like my
question on it I actually think Rotten
Tomatoes is right on this I do think
Goodfellas is better but I actually
think casino is worse because Martin
Scorsese grew as a filmmaker in that
time period but he regressed as far as
what he chose to do with this film I
completely agree yes he actually became
a better filmmaker in that time and so
the look of Casino so that's 79 you
think is too high yeah I actually do for
for what he actually does on screen
because this is the difference between
the audience score and the critic score
of this one and then I want to take us
to movies to two minutes with Tim real
quick yeah is the audience is passion
and the passion that Martin Scorsese has
for these characters and these people is
evident through everything that he does
his skill has risen throughout all of
the Endeavors that he's done since I
mean he did Cape Fear after this and
Kate fear to me the year after he's just
yeah killing the game Martin Scorsese in
my opinion as far as what he could be in
his best sentiments and by the time he
gets to casino he's retreating back into
himself to try and make his John Ford
epic about
uh subject matter that was not built for
John Ford epics Cape Fear came out the
year after Goodfellas and it was up to
that point it was his most commercially
successful film counselor but yeah oh
yeah the last scene on the boat in the
rain yeah uh is is crazy it's so so good
but yeah you're right I I think that he
was evolving as a filmmaker and and uh
you know when Casino came out in 95 it
was like scarcity putting on a comfy
pair of slippers right especially after
the age of Innocence which was which was
a period piece yeah
people didn't understand but let's hold
on before we start going too far let's
listen to what Tim had to say take us
back to 95 and 90 because there's a lot
of context that he could give us and
let's take it away Brian with the music
cue two minutes with Tim
two minutes with Tim before we get into
this I want to say that I think
Goodfellas is a better movie but I've
probably seen Casino in bits and pieces
dozens more times back when I had cable
and I would be channel surfing it seemed
like Casino was always on albeit was
some of the more colorful language
edited out
I'd stumble upon everyone was clicking
through channels and I'd say to myself I
guess I know what I'm doing for the next
couple hours but anyway here's the
breakdown Goodfellas from 1990 is
certified fresh at 96 on the Tomato
Meter with 105 reviews and it has a 97
audience score Casino from 1995 is
certified fresh at 79 with 70 reviews
and it has a 93 audience score so what
did the critics have to say in a fresh
review of Goodfellas Sheila Benson of
the Los Angeles Times wrote Goodfellas
which somehow mixes its Horrors with a
deep vein of mordant humor flows with
the exuberance of a filmmaker who has
every detail nailed and a few lovely
moves he wants to show us in a fresh
review of Casino Janet Maslin of the New
York Times wrote of all the Bravo visual
effects in Martin scorsese's dazzlingly
stylish Casino it's a glimpse of
ordinary people that delivers the
greatest jolt the Rotten Tomatoes critic
consensus for Goodfellas reads
hard-hitting and stylish Goodfellas is a
gangster classic and arguably the high
point of Martin scorsese's career the
Rotten Tomatoes critics consensus for
Casino reads impressive ambition and
Bravo performances from an outstanding
cast helped Casino pay off in spite of a
familiar narrative that may strike some
viewers as a safe bet for director
Martin Scorsese so that's good Fellas in
Casino let's get back to Jacqueline and
Mark who are the kind of folks who root
for the bad guys in the movies that's
actually fair is that true depend ends
on the movie yeah sure if they have an
ethos I usually understand
as far back as I can remember I always
wanted to be a gangster a podcast
look I don't want to get too far into
the I do like what Tim says about casino
because he is right about that that I
feel like Casino was way more prevalent
like Casino was a TNT movie that you saw
all the time and Goodfellas for some
reason it was Infamous with its violence
I don't think they could cut around it
as well well first of all with with
Goodfellas I've seen the movie so many
times like so many times and it's the
kind of movie I could watch anytime any
day no matter what mood I'm in if you
wanted to stop and pause right now and
watch it right now I'd be totally
totally down for that and and it's not a
movie I need to re-watch because I have
seen it so many times but to prep for
this podcast I had to go back and watch
casino because I haven't seen it in a
really long time so I watched it and
once sitting three hours and 15 minutes
and I'm just like yeah it really is like
Goodfellas in Vegas it's it the
characters are are not as interesting
the the story is not as as fully defined
uh it's it doesn't have that like like
more defined Arc like Goodfellas has uh
but it's still a really really good
movie it's just that you know how do you
follow Goodfellas with the same movie
and not get compared to Goodfellas yeah
which I think that's what critics were
talking about at the time and that's
definitely what we're going to be
talking about a little bit at the time
before we get a bit of a Martin Scorsese
history lesson so let's go ahead and
move on into movie talk
[Music]
I really feel weird even doing this
because I think Martin scorsese's
daughter
um who gives him Marvel wrapped
Christmas presents every year probably
maybe listens to Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong but there is not a fiber of my
being that will allow myself the thought
that he will ever hear this but I will
say it's it's a it's an interesting
thing because I feel Martin Scorsese has
done so much for films and filmmaking
and the preservation and such a great
film historian he's such a great
champion of this thing that we've all in
some way shape or form dedicated our
life to
but being a fan of his work when you
look at it now in the grander sense and
when you look at it now when he talks
about where movies are for me is much
more complicated
it is much more complicated to
see Martin Scorsese as this
established filmmaker nearing the end of
their career lament over what privileges
they're no longer available to them when
I realized that was privileges that were
never available for black female or
brown filmmakers so it's like a hard
thing for me so it's a weird thing for
me to be a fan of Martin's Scorsese now
I think it's easier for y'all but like
what is it like for you being a fan of
him well just in terms of Martin
Scorsese and like you know there's
always a comment on Twitter like he
thinks the Marvel movies or Theater Park
rides or anything like that I afford
people who are his age yeah a few get
off my lawn moments yeah I'm 42 and I
have those so sure if I was like oh come
on Mark this guy's 80
I give him but it does make being a fan
of his more complicated as I get older
but it makes a fan of being Quentin
Tarantino more complicated is over as I
get older and that doesn't mean that
either one of them are not filmmakers
where if they make another movie I'm not
queuing it well the other thing that I
think we've had to rectify with our with
our modern society and how we know
everybody's dirty laundry now is that
you have to separate art from artists
sometimes absolutely it's less about me
holding a poster of Martin Scorsese in
my bedroom but I can still put a poster
of either Goodfellas or the king of
comedy or Hugo in my bedroom and and I
it's so hard for me to say as Tim did
that Goodfellas is the height of Martin
scorsese's career because I feel like
he's not a single Peak kind of filmmaker
I feel like he's the Himalayas I feel
like there's a bunch of incredible Peaks
for sure this might be his Everest but
there's a lot of there's a lot of really
tall mountains I I think first of all
when it comes to Score says he you know
making a making a comment about like
superhero movies I mean look he's not
wrong I don't blame him for feeling that
way as much as I love the Marvel and DC
movies myself sometimes I get a little
sick of that stuff too I'm not gonna lie
and again I'm not even faulting him in
it what I'm saying is it makes being a
fan of his now more complicated I see I
I hear your point and but I just feel
like Scorsese has
he is continually tried to challenge
himself and he is continue to try to be
be very ambitious you know whether or
not you think the Irishman is too long
sure three and a half hours yeah it is
but you know here you have a filmmaker
who's doing stuff like The Departed and
silence and the Irishman by also doing
documentaries on Bob Dylan and George
Harrison and the stones man the stones
and the band so I think this guy is
always doing something and whether he's
80 years old this year I I think it's
pretty cool that he is still pushing
himself and challenging himself I don't
disagree I I I'm not even talking about
the Marvel thing because like they are
theme park rides it's why Disney owns
them
come on now I'm not in any illusion on
that I'm more talking about what he's
saying now about how commercialistic
movies have gotten and how like you know
it's much more about the bottom line
movie should make a profit but this is
Art and look I've studied black
exploitation the reason why black
exploitation exists is because nobody
gave any of the money and when new
Hollywood people like that were coming
up through corpsman like Coppola and
Spielberg and all those folks were
coming through one of the reasons why
they were able to get pushed through to
the studio system was because they did
not have to be forced out of it and they
could go through the launching Pad but
but Jacqueline you know I think that
Score says his point has more to do with
with just the way the times have changed
because even him wait for him no no hang
on just a minute hear me out here
because even before kovit what was
happening there was turning out to be a
bigger gap between the types of movies
that people were going to see in
theaters and the types of millions that
people were going to stay home and watch
on streaming services and all that all
that the pandemic did was It sped that
process up where you have a much much
bigger gap between the types of movies
that people were going to see in
theaters which is the comic book stuff
theme park rides the theme park rides
because you got to leave your house to
go to a theme park right and you know
when I saw top gun Maverick which I love
is my favorite movie of 2022 I love top
gun Maverick I saw in theaters five
times I love the hell out of that movie
and that movie brought a lot of people
back to theaters who hadn't been to the
movies since before March of 2020 but it
is there's still a gap there's still a
gap which is why so many movies now are
you know like mid-budget low budget
they're just going straight to Amazon
Netflix Hulu Disney plus Paramount plus
uh peacock and and I get it and I get it
and I I think that that for Scorsese I
think that part of his I mean I I can't
speak for him okay but I think that
there is like when I hear him say stuff
like that I think that that's part of it
I think that it's just that that people
are more but that's not he says
specifically he finds it disturbing and
sometimes disgusting that now and the
quote exactly was everything is bent on
a commercialistic bent like they're the
first thought is is this gonna make any
money and he's not wrong and what I
would say to him is this is just a very
clear statement there is not a single
black filmmaker that has not been the
consent the the situation from the get
there's not a single female filmmaker
where that has not been the
consideration from the get so you're
saying that that script says he's
feeling now what black filmmakers were
feeling in the 70s this is exactly what
black panthers that's what's frustrating
to me is because I saw
when these situations happen what does
end up happening usually is other things
pop off and I'm more interested from the
type of movies that are gonna be born
out of these new Financial imperatives
because I think they're going to be
avant-garde I think they're going to be
interesting I think they're going to
live in different places and I think
they're going to really show us because
that's what black exploitation did the
entire 90s uh sort of action movement
was built off of black exploitation
which was born out of exclusion but I
think that's the great thing about
artists and whether whether you're
talking about a filmmaker like Scorsese
or you're talking about anybody else in
really any other line of artistic
Endeavor when you are handcuffed this
sucks but you tend to use your artistic
ability and your sensibilities to figure
out a way to get out of that and yeah
like Shyamalan did when he went back to
Glass yeah yeah the most the most
obvious example is a Steve the shark
isn't working today yeah um we got to
figure something else out and so you
just you have these hurdles that you
have to overcome much more so that are
societal as far as what Jacqueline's
talking about but with a guy like Martin
Scorsese who's 80 or somebody who wants
to be a young Scorsese you're figuring
your way out to make a movie and to get
it seen to get eyeballs on it that is
outside of just that theme park system
as he would say but I would Point
anybody who's an aspiring filmmaker to
look at Goodfellas and casino not just
in terms of hey it's a really good movie
right but I would challenge especially
with casino because I think we can all
agree there's some fat to be trimmed
there yeah I'm not sure I'm not smart
enough to know where it is but when I'm
watching because the big difference yes
between Goodfellas and casinos to me is
that I feel like when I'm watching
casinos especially in one sitting like
you did Scott is I'll get to be about
two hours in and I'm like wait have we
already seen this yeah
and I love it everything but when I I
find myself missing in casino that I I
that I get in Goodfellas is a Ray Liotta
yeah is somebody who's just driving that
action yeah yeah well well the in Casino
De Niro's character Sam Rothman
Rothstein is the one driving the action
but Sam Rothstein is not as interesting
as Henry Hill he's just not right also
let's look at Goodfellas for what it is
Henry Hill the actual man was a drug
addict a womanizer like literally the
most despicable degenerate you would
ever meet and the biggest conceit of
Goodfellas is making him seem like a
good guy for the first hour you know
what I mean he's a good fella like
that's the heels to show him as a kid
yeah it really does help because we got
room for a kid well because because
you're also seeing because you do show
him as a kid you're seeing the loss of
Innocence yes and you don't have that in
Casino no so one thing I will say with
with Goodfellas that I found the
difference and I I think you touched on
it one I still feel Martin scorsese's
like independent came up outside of you
know the studio assistant Coppola sort
of mentality in making Goodfellas
because if you really look at his
filmography he went to more established
things in the middle until he he got to
the king of comedy and king of comedy
was such like a left field turn for him
in so many ways that I really feel like
with Good Fellas this was him trying to
return back to what he had with Mean
Streets well okay you brought up I'm
glad you brought up the 80s yeah because
starting with Raging Bull which
technically is a 70s movie even though
it came out in 1980 the 1980 is still
considered the 70s it is just for the
record on that even though when it comes
to best movies of the 80s it's always
very difficult right so here's the thing
about about the 80s and about the king
of comedy which is one of my favorite
movies of all time I know you love it
too Mr pumpkin you know better to be
king for a night than schmuck for a
lifetime agreed but but listen so the
80s are the most misunderstood decade of
Martin scorsese's career because after
the 70s which I think is his most
crucial period of time when you had Mean
Streets when you had obviously taxi
driver but all also the underrated New
York New York in 77 and The Last Waltz
in 78 one of the best concert movies
ever made period I think that's his his
most fruitful period but then after
Raging Bull he does the king of comedy
which is which at the time was
misunderstood mixed reviews and then
after hours which hardly anyone saw very
very mixed reviews and then the color of
money which at the time got negative
reviews now on Rotten Tomatoes all three
of those movies the Rotten Tomato scores
are very very very very certified fresh
with like the high 80s of the low 90s
and I think the reason for that is a lot
of those newer reviews are done by
people looking back versus at the time
so the reason I bring that up is because
in the documentary life itself about
Roger Ebert so Scorsese is interviewed
for that and there's a great moment in
that film when says he says I remember
when Roger Ebert reviewed the color of
money and he gave it a bad review and he
said you know you're better than this he
said I mean I'm paraphrasing he didn't
actually see it but he says really come
on Marty you are better than this I'll
give you a pass for now but that's it
the next one better be better and you
see Scorsese talking about it like that
Martin Scorsese was hurt by that it's
like a coach yeah telling you you got to
give more of an effort in the game but
looking back on those films color money
is a great film it's the only movie in
which Paul Newman won a competitive
acting Oscar for lead actor for for you
know fast Eddie phels
um after hours is a wild film I love
that movie really really on the ground
is the only one on that one I feel is
horribly
um misunderstood but not for the ways
you think and color of money is just a
good movie that had the mistake of
casting Tom Cruise but I'm telling you
uh the king of comedy is was ahead of
its time it got great reviews when it
came out and was called The Joker I well
I
uh which Martin Scorsese actually
produced on so that was like the other
thing is like he got he got his movie to
best picture however many years later a
few decades a few decades later so but I
understand why people would call
Goodfellas the Pinnacle of his career
because at least up and like that it
felt like everything that he had done up
until 1990 had sort of culminated with
goodfells but it was also sort of a look
back and like sort of a more updated
Mean Streets at least it had that sort
of feel but you also just had these
characters these this triumphant and and
God loved Paul Sorvino uh rest in peace
I always felt like like sometimes he's
on the poster but I always felt like
he's just he's the guy in the background
and then you have De Niro and Leota and
Pesci but when front when you see the
images when you see the from that photo
session when you see Paul cervino with
them it's pretty cool Paul cervino's
Paulie he he's the guy behind the guy
behind the guy right okay when he shows
up you know what what is it that that
Henry Hill says you know Paulie didn't
say much he wasn't he didn't move fast
he didn't have to yeah uh no one got no
one really had access to Paulie uh I I
love her Paul servino's character in
that film in fact I love all of the
characters in that film I think the
characters one of the main characters
the supporting characters or even the
characters he just kind of like see for
a second are much much more memorable
and iconic and more defined than in
Casino remember that scene in the bar
and near the beginning of Goodfellas
after Henry Hill turns into Ray Liotta
is he goes into bar oh and this is uh
you know uh uh uh Nicki eyes and this is
uh Jimmy two times because he said
everything twice I'm gonna go get the
papers get the papers yeah I want to
know what happens to Jimmy Two Times
also 32 times I know someone who has
written a like spec scripts prequel on
stacks
uh basically how did Stacks end up
getting shot oh right that whole story
how did he end up with these white boys
asleep at the wheel yeah and it was like
a really tragic tale because it talks
about his girlfriend and like really
what happened and like the rumor was
that he got high and like but it wasn't
that wasn't really what happened oh yeah
yeah so it's like this whole idea of
like Stacks getting set up and I know
somebody that wrote that but that's the
whole point every one of those Martin
Scorsese characters you could write a
whole backstory on and it's tough for me
if I had to give you my favorite scene
in Goodfellas it's it is impossible to
do and it's really dependent on my move
like there's some movies where I'm like
that's the best scene in the movie yeah
with this one you could obviously point
to that extended shot when he's walking
to the back of the restaurant love it in
fact that shot by the way was so iconic
that when it came to swingers in 1996
director by Doug Lyman like he basically
recreated that shot when they're walking
through the uh I think it's the the
swing club was it um was it the Dresden
or or or or anyway talking about that
shot in the movie yeah and they're just
a bunch of actors so you know it took
him three days to light that it's just
yeah and then you see them do it
themselves right yeah yeah and but but
the one that I love currently is I I
love Pesci's hot-headedness and so into
the clown scene but I love the shine box
scene that scene kills me because it's
such a great example and if you don't
know what they're all they're all
hanging out of the bar and then another
group comes in and they're with a
different crew and and the crews have a
respect for each other so you don't
touch one another but Pesci used to work
and used to shine the shoes of this guy
and so this guy is reminding Joe Pesci
of where he came from and Pesci's got a
date with him and he's ah yeah he feels
like he's being embarrassed he just has
to keep saying it and it's the problem
with being in the mob is it's just never
enough you gotta go back to the cookie
jar one more time you gotta do one more
job you gotta do one more kill and this
poor bastard Billy bat says Go Get Your
Shine bar and he just can't really loses
it if this is just not said that and
just gone back to his party everything
would have been cool yeah he would not
have he would not have been whacked he
would have been knocked off which would
which eventually led to Tommy being
black as a man now I'm glad you brought
that scene up the shine box scene
because that scene is very reminisce in
good in a casino of the pen yes the pen
scene in Casino equals the shine box
scene in I always thought the um the
micro Imperioli scene and um that was
the pin because it basically this idea
of both of these movies that at any
point violence can be the response to
anything literally anything and that's
why the clown scene is so good because
you don't know yes if Joe Pesci is
actually upset with Leota yes and that
is actually what sets the framework for
that like of everything later of like
this dude will kill people right for the
most like slight kill people yes and
guess what so will Jimmy the chain I'll
get to that in a second yeah the the
most iconic scene of Goodfellas of
perhaps Martin scorsese's movies period
is why am I funny what makes me funny
yeah
because because here's the thing no
matter how many times you watch
Goodfellas when you get to that moment
you're like uh oh here we go yeah it
makes you feel just as uncomfortable the
30th time as it did the first time yeah
and you know you're really like like
Henry is like uh he's scared like he's
scared and then he just like blinked his
eyes he goes get the hell out of here
Tommy you know but that scene it's just
one of the most quoted one of the most
referenced one of the most famous scenes
of Scorsese if not movies of the of the
80s and the 90s
um and I just don't think that casino
has a moment like that I I think that
the pet scene is is a great scene I
think that the scene when Ginger played
by uh Golden Globe winner Sharon Stone
when she goes back to to to De Niro's
home to get her stuff and the cops are
there that's a great scene just because
the two of them are such great actors
and she was also nominated for that uh
but I just don't think that casino
there's no one scene of casino that is
as good as as a bunch of individual
scenes in Goodfellas well I think the
thing with Goodfellas in that scene in
particular that you're talking about
with the clown is it's one of these few
scenes in the movies that tells the
movie in the scene
everything that is important about good
fillers you know all the characters you
know the characters you know the stakes
you know how dangerous this can be and
even Tommy with his joke you may falter
under questioning it also gives you the
preview of what's going to happen later
so it's like the scene in Edgar Wright's
um uh in Sean of the Dead where they say
what they're gonna do you know we're
gonna drop Mary's like it's it's that
it's like the scene in the middle of tar
when she's sitting with her mentor and
she's basically talking about what's
going to happen to her by the end of the
movie really really masterful movies can
bring what they are down to one
essential scene put it in the middle of
a movie that can then tell that story
tangentially and you're right there is a
scene like that in casino but the stupid
thing is it's only the 30 seconds at the
beginning of the movie right before he
blows up oh right right yeah also at the
end at the end so basically it just
bookends it and it's not really one big
scene it's just in 30 seconds of him
sitting in that car kind of talking
through how he got here and the
loneliness of him being here thinking
back to Sharon and then he blows up
that's Casino I I you know when I was
re-watching casino and I was watching
the end of casino and Sam Rothstein Ace
is thinking of how how all the real
casinos were demolished to make way for
Disneyland in Las Vegas and I'm thinking
this is Martin Scorsese who shot taxi
driver in Times Square in the 70s when
it was dirty and grimy and dangerous and
now Times Square New York is like this
anyway but but you know all this talk
about Tommy and Joe Pesci is basically
playing a I would say a uh a more muted
version of the same character in casino
but Jimmy the Gent
to Nero in Goodfellas they call him
Jimmy the gem for a reason because you
know he's smiling he's he he thinks that
he makes you think that you're on his
side and like that moment after the
shine box when when uh everyone exits
the bar and the door is closed and then
you know you see you know Jimmy the
giant you see you know De Niro is
stepping on the guy's face and then
there's the whole moment uh after the
Lufthansa Heist when Jimmy gets paranoid
and he starts knocking off the other
Wise Guys yeah yeah I think the other
thing too is remember in the moment when
they kill Billy Batts uh Ray Liotta
Henry Hill is at first horrified he
didn't think it was going to happen it
was just the same way when um they
didn't think they were going to kill the
mattress rug guy the guy with the with
the toupee what was his name I forget
his name that's uh no no the other guy
the the guy that was like given no not
bats the other guy the guy that Robert
De Niro who had the Morty Morty the guy
with the rug I'll board it yeah yeah
yeah
that guy when I want my money I want my
money when when they kill him that night
again in the car Henry is so naive he
literally just believes that these
people are gonna make it out of the
violence because he made it out of all
the violence but he's also willing to
subscribe to the violence if need be
yeah and another one of my favorite
scenes is the pistol whip scene because
he hears that uh you know Lorraine
Bracco calls him frantic and he comes
home that's my favorite scene but if I
can tell it there well I have at it
thank you I was going to say because
Ashanti's foolish uh is my favorite
scene uh like I was actually gonna set
it up this way I like how Goodfellas
permeated the culture in a way that
casino did not and it wasn't because
that wasn't the time the movies could
permeate the culture the Age of
Innocence permeated the culture more
than Casino did in a lot of ways
especially with women of my age but the
scene when Lorraine Bracco is
confronting Henry Hill I think is the
biggest comedy of the world uh when she
with uh she's sitting on him sitting on
him because he's dating Janet Ross you
know the the [__] that she's buzzing on
her door her pointing that gun to him is
the most hilarious things it's like
giving drug dealers the death penalty as
if this guy is not literally existing
with a gun to his head every day he does
not care about you
so of course you
see a little bit of domestic violence
but I just love the comedy of her
thinking that her love and what was
between her legs which is literally
holding him down with and a gun could
keep this man from getting in the
streets that's the dumbest thing ever I
loved it I feel like the Cena casino
that I find myself gearing up for and
that I'm waiting not to the level of the
clown scene but it's when Ace and his
cronies at the casino catch those two
who are trying to game the system oh
right yeah and they take him back and
they smash into his hand because it also
gives me some Don Rickles screen time
and I love the Don Rickles is this
manager
Las Vegas is is the assistant manager at
the casino that's wonderful to me but I
also find myself oddly looking forward
to every scene with James Woods because
he's just so skeezy in it and she just
can't quit him and I just want ginger to
graduate well this is the thing with her
her dice scene is an incredible
character introduction that is a great
character introduction just her throwing
it up uh throwing all the chips yeah
like that that whole scene and that's a
great character introduction scene
because she doesn't say hardly anything
in that scene and you know exactly who
she is and what she's about and also why
Robert De Niro is instantly besotted
with her I I love you know both of those
movies use music in the same way they
use a soundtrack to to propel the story
forward as a score you know the songs
move into one another and move into one
another you know some songs are used for
like just a few seconds some for much
much longer so so there's also that
style of Casino that's very similar to
Goodfellas but I think that good Fellas
does a much much better job of the music
I mean every time you you say those
words as far back as I could remember I
always wanted to be a gangster how could
I go for brags to riches but also to
this day
no matter where I am driving if I'm just
out somewhere and I hear the music over
a loudspeak or Whatever Whenever I hear
Derek and the Domino's Leyland in my
mind's eye I am thinking of all the Wise
Guys turning up dead after the Lufthansa
Heist because Jimmy had them whacked
because he was getting too paranoid I
also love the ending credits hearing Sid
Vicious seeing Frank Sinatra's My Way
yeah yeah um
I will have to say the ending of
Goodfellas as much as I love that movie
I do feel it just it doesn't stick The
Landing I think it does absolutely well
with Henry Hill in the newspaper no he's
getting the newspaper and then there's
that hill was still a drug addict at the
end he should have just been showing him
as a drug addict but but that that that
moment of him getting in the newspaper
looking into the camera breaking the
fourth wall smiling and then there's
that that throwback to The Great Train
Robbery of the cowboy shooting the gun
at the camera only in this case it's
Tommy emptying his pistol into the
camera and then you hear my way that is
just a that's that gets me the chills to
see Tommy to see Joe Percy point the gun
at the camera
Stinger because they knew how flat the
minute before that no no I I think that
was a bit of trickery I think I was
actually surprised when I rewatched
Goodfellas because I forgot about the
gun shooting at the camera I thought it
was just Henry Hill in the newspaper
then just then this breaks the fourth
wall for a minute so I forgot about that
that that little post yeah yeah and then
most people don't know that that's a
that's a call back yes that Score says
he's you know right Vlog and now it's an
appreciation going back to the Great
Train Robbery well this is what I was
saying so that great trainer ought to be
it's a big Epic film like sure the
kicker is what I was trying to say I
think Goodfellas he wanted it to feel
like casino but he didn't have the
resources skill time whatever to make it
as Grand and as big as he did and so
that's why I feel like Casino again just
feels like a do-over and a do-over for
something that he didn't need to do over
but dude I like Scott's question earlier
that he posed at the Top If Casino had
came out first is that the movie we're
all talking about because I still feel
like Goodfellas is the better movie I
think Goodfellas is the better movie but
Jacqueline Jacqueline if Casino came out
first I know it's hard to hard to erase
Goodfellas from your mind and just look
at casino try try to just imagine that
casino that that good Fellas never
happened and it's 1990 and casino is
this first movie in theaters do I think
that that's the movie we would be
talking about here the age of yes
he Dances with Wolves well if Goodfellas
didn't beat dance with Wolves there's no
way casinos that's the reason why I'm
saying it's like I I am going back to
that time and that's what I'm trying to
tell you those movies didn't work like
that back then they've started to work
like that now the gangster movie like
we're thinking of it that Martin
Scorsese was doing I don't think if they
were reversed it would have changed it
because at the time the sentiments and
taste said that this type of movie
wasn't it yet and that's why he tried to
elevate it and it still didn't work well
I love I love dancing with Wolves I mean
you know for people who say oh my God
you know I can't believe Goodfellas
didn't win and and dancing with Wolves
won best picture of a good Fellas you
know they always put down Dancing With
Wolves when they say that when in fact
Dancing With Wolves is a beautiful Epic
film and that is why it won because it
was a sweeping moving epic and it was
more like the great dream ever uh yeah
it kind of was and that's what I'm
trying to say it's like it's the
difference between you know Saving
Private Ryan versus you know Shakespeare
in Love and I get why people prefer the
big epic but wait a minute hang on the
reason that dancing with wolves that
Dances with Wolves won over Goodfellas
it's the same reason that that The
King's Speech won over the social
network yes the social network is a much
much better film it is a movie that that
that is so much more stylistic has so
much more going on but you know the King
speech it was a safer it so that's why
people picked it I I I I think that much
had changed not and that's also why I
think Casino as much as it is a much
safer Moreau Tour Version when you get
down to it at that time those people's
tastes were not going that way and fun
fact the icing on the cake or the point
they all were making what did win the
year Casino came out oh bye-bye
Braveheart
that's right exactly pretty big sweeping
up exactly yeah and so but it wasn't
even nominated and casino wasn't even
nominant and you got to look at it this
way the kind of sweeping epic they like
war movies uh big uh romances like The
English Patient or Titanic think about
those tastes at the time there's no
taste at the time because if you look
back to just a few years ago a big War
epic did not win best picture it went to
parasites exactly so the tastes have
changed that is the reason why I think
by the way I called it right here on
Ryan this is what happened
experts in the room talking about Martin
Scorsese
and so the crazy thing about his career
when you look at it is that the guys won
one best directing Oscar and it was for
The Departed which is a movie that I
find very rewatchable but I don't put it
in his top five best movies I love The
Departed but it's not nearly as good as
good and he's not it's not it's a
Scorsese movie because he made it but
it's not a Scorsese movie I agree it's
more it's more like a dial back yes
compared to casino and to Goodfellas
exactly and to
um you know one movie we haven't really
talked about much in comparing the style
of casino and Goodfellas is The Wolf of
Wall Street uh because it has that voice
over that fast editing and also that
three hour running time and a much more
Despicable lead which is necessary for
this I think we've got it but I will
give you sir Mr Scott mans the final
thoughts uh I'm Mr Martin Scorsese
because I feel like you will place him
in a better thing because I think anyone
listening to this is gonna feel like a
monster kid I'm not there's probably 10
films in this filmography that it would
easily be something that I would go on a
desert island with including a movie
like silence and Alice doesn't live here
anymore two films that we didn't even
mention today that are like lesser
popular versions of this movie known as
the classic Scorsese movies which is why
I put Hugo in there too Hugo blew me
away and he comes crazy a guy with the
talent and the knowledge of film history
like Martin Scorsese could could make it
could could have made that movie it was
that 2011 2011 yes it was wow
what's your final thought to wish this
man an actual happy birthday with a
little bit less of my Melancholy I would
say listen I mean the guy's 80 years old
I think I love that he is still like
really busy uh you know he's he's
working on a film right now that I know
that he wrapped what's with the Leonardo
DiCaprio uh that that a lot of people
thought might come out this year but
it's not going to happen but I just
think that the fact that he is still
challenging himself at 80 years old that
he's still pushing himself that that
he's still so busy is his hand did so
many things whether it's documentaries
or feature films and and it's been like
that since since basically the early 70s
with mean streets and I just think that
that that when Martin Square says he
puts out a new film and I feel this way
about Spielberg too what score says he
puts out a new film it's like getting a
new Beatles album now we're not getting
new beetles apps but we are getting like
a new a new Martin Scorsese movie like
like I love that the Fable man's is a
new Spielberg movie he is still
directing films he is still challenging
himself when you think of Scorsese you
know your your your quick thought or
Scorsese is Good Fellas his taxi driver
is is The Departed is Raging Bull uh
maybe not the Departed but those three
films alone Taxi Driver Goodfellas and
Raging Bull three of the greatest movies
ever ever made and uh and he's still
making yeah that is uh that is a great
Epitaph for this sort of like
remembrance even though he's still with
us
uh but yeah no I think that's a good
place to place him we're gonna go ahead
and open up the mailbag because we're
not just talking Martin Scorsese we have
some folks that have written in so Brian
cue the music
okay this week we have ketchup crew
members Stacy Packham and I just
finished listening to your recently
released podcast of the top 10 scariest
movies and I was surprised there weren't
any mentions of the original Amityville
Horror sorry Stacy that list was trash I
lived in a massive three-story house
built in the 1890s and we had a few
scares while living there so the two
scariest memories are the red eyes of
Jody outside of the youngest daughter's
bedroom as well as the Sinister voice to
tell the priest get ouch
jeez when I first read this I thought
that happened it's Stacy's house I'm
serious
I'm a new listener as of today's
episodes Oh Stacy and I really enjoyed
your conversation with the co-host hey
Stacy appreciate you glad you're a new
listener we could always use those I'm
not trashing our scariest horror movies
list but it was much more an iconic
horror movies list to me than a scary
Harley yeah Amityville always just feels
like it gets slighted a little bit from
your exorcists and your Omens and your
other like classic 70 these horror
movies Halloween it just it feels like
it's that next tier but as far as the
premise alone goes it's as horrifying as
anything when I saw that movie when it
came out I was terrified and I remember
watching a news report on the real story
of the Lutz's uh you know and that
because it was based on a true story
just just made it scarier but I don't
think it's as well made as I mean my
favorite Haunted House movie of all time
my favorite scary movie of all time a
movie that I literally just watched on
Halloween night and it's still scared
the hell out of me is The Shining there
it is really The Shining is the shiny
didn't scare me the first time I watched
him I love that I found it funny it's
not funny I found him funny yeah well
you weren't staying in room 237. stay
out stay out of room 237 I was dirtier
weaving the shower I'm not saying it's
not a scary movie this movie was
unfortunately a product of Pop Culture
before it was something that I watched
and so all of the iconic things that
were supposed to be in uncanny valley I
was like oh that's from The Simpsons
yeah
and that happens sometimes
you know well it wasn't that that's just
where I saw it first obviously because
nobody was letting me watch The Shining
when I was seeing when you watch when
you watch like a uh an iconic moment
reenacted for for laughs and then you go
back and watch it in the way that it was
originally intended it's just never it's
not yeah that's what I'm saying so like
don't get me wrong I know The Shining is
scary but that movie in particular I saw
it the wrong way everything I saw in it
funny yeah I think I could watch The
Exorcist now but I still I'm gonna avoid
that I stay away from it to myself Scott
thank you so much for joining us and
Stacy thank you so much for your email
and for listening in thank you for being
a ketchup crew member you can be cool
like Stacy just email us at Rotten
Tomatoes is wrong at RT is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com and don't forget to
rate review And subscribe wherever you
see us but before we get out of here
Scott sir please let folks know where
they can find you well you can find me
on Twitter and Instagram at movie Mance
that's what they TZ so uh yeah shoot me
a tweet or or follow me there and I'm
very active on social media so I will
engage it's always a good like when you
get one from Scott it is it is good like
uh have you uh got a movie
recommendation for us sir besides Top
Gun which you have definitely put been
in the chair I love that movie I love
Top Gun it is the best movie of the year
I think it is okay okay but besides Top
Gun oh okay uh I'll go with the
fablements okay is uh one of many movies
that for some reason all these great
directors are going back and doing their
personal films Kenneth Brown I just want
to his screenplay Academy Awards this
started it was in this iteration was
Alfonso right Alfonso sure with uh first
one and then they've all been doing yeah
not just the males Charlotte Wells has
after sun there's a few but uh but the
Fable men's is is a culmination of a lot
of things because when you watch
Spielberg's film and you realize his
family dynamic in in ways that are
subtle and not very subtle have made
their way into so many of his films over
the years like Close Encounters in E.T
and poltergeists and
um
I just think it's a wonderful film yeah
I I say my favorite part of that is the
Old Masters conversation he has in it uh
I think John Ford makes a great Cameo
you guys got me in the theater all right
that is it for us today
um thank you again Scott oh hey speaking
of the king of comedy what my specialty
is December 3rd in L.A you can get
tickets at markellis.live it's right
here in Los Angeles December 3rd two
shows the new hour special I will
actually be here you're gonna kidnap me
aren't you no yeah you should because
yeah yeah we still have yet to see
YouTube comedy despite all of my efforts
and I still think I've seen you but the
person I live with has not and I don't
think he believes me when I say that
you're a comedian he knows you're funny
and I still say I still say to everyone
watching and listening to this podcast
Mark Ellis I still challenge you to see
a movie you have never seen before a
movie that I've recommended to you that
is streaming on HBO Max because you look
so all much like Richard Jordan that you
need to watch Logan's Run oh thank you
very much because if we didn't have Star
Wars in 77 you had Logan's Run at 76. I
will do it for you thank you yep thank
you gentlemen for the tour of the 70s
okay we're gonna see you next week on
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong ladies and
gentlemen we want to thank y'all for
listening
[Music]
thank you